[Music]
welcome on into NHL puckline I'm Lauren Jabara
here with Drew goldar and Drew I have not seen
you since Thanksgiving weekend how was your
break how was your Thanksgiving did you do
anything fun uh not as quite as eventful as yours
Congratulations by the way but yeah it was good a
lot of good food and uh some some football some
hockey over the weekend saw my favorite wrestler
make his return to WWE CM Punk is back I know
his mask is is off camera but hey best in the
world is back uh he's just there to make money not
to make friends we're here to both make money and
make friends so uh you know that but that yeah
very exciting weekend that should be the slogan
for the show make money make friends let's get
into it there's three games on the Slate tonight
after a lot last night and there's going to be a
heck of a lot of games tomorrow where we're going
to have an extended show but tonight three games
on the Slate the Habs in Columbus to take on the
Blue Jackets we have the Red Wings in the bag Big
Apple taking on the New York Rangers and last but
not least the Caps have headed from the nation's
capital all the way to the Left Coast to take on
the Los Angeles Kings let's get right into it
havs Blue Jackets will send you to Columbus for
the Canadians right now they've won two of the
last three against the Blue Jackets last year
and this year they sitting second from bottom
in the Atlantic kind of what you'd expect from
a team that's starting to rebuild a little bit
more try to find their footing underneath them
on the offensive side though Cole Coffield leads
the way the team overall averaging 2.71 goals per
game bottom six in the league there's been a
lack Drew of secondary scoring at this point
but Alex new hook he's embraced his new team
so far this season he has 12 points in 21 games
after spending his first couple years with the
Colorado Avalanche what have you thought about
him really pushing that first line I mean the pace
that he's on is outstanding for him especially I
mean we know obviously very young player being
only in his third season but these would all be
new career highs if he keeps this pace he's on
Pace for 23 goals 23 assists and 113 shots which
that wouldn't be a career high but that's not
really quite the most important of Statistics
uh he's been very efficient in producing goals
six goals on just 29 shots uh talk about a lot
of the time I bring up the idea of regression of
the mean positive or negative uh a 20% shooting
percentage probably not sustainable longterm for
him but he's been very good and you talked about
the younger players as well Cole Caulfield Nick
Suzuki also 17 points through 21 games so uh they
they've been getting some Productions from some
of their younger guys for the Montreal Canadians
so even though the winds aren't coming just yet
I'm sure that long term that is something that
they're looking forward to and hey there's a CM
Punk Mas sitting right over there over my shoulder
I really really like it I know this team has a
lot of exciting young pieces there's a lot to be
optimistic about if you are a Habs fan for years
to come but they do need to build around that I
feel like this season though they need a little
bit more from a guy like Shawn Monahan he's been
off the score sheet for six straight games he's
a veteran in this league what do you need to see
a little bit more from him to really get the Habs
going I I actually saw him I was at the game with
Montreal was here in Las Vegas when he played
the golden kns and he was a real standout player
he was making things happen in that game for me I
noticed him quite a bit in that one so to see him
not getting the production not getting on the
point sheet it's going to be something I think
that he turns around a bit uh but it it's just
kind of a difficult position for him right now
I think and uh you know he'll he'll make things
work again in the future because he is a talented
player but it's a bit of that streakiness and
right now he's just not on the good side of that
streakiness but again talk about regression of the
mean at some point it'll break back through is he
going to be that Topline player that may maybe
some people thought he might have been you know
maybe not but he's not uh longterm going to have
to be that guy for the Montreal Canadians anyway
so uh if I mean if he plays anything like he did
when I saw him playing against the golden knights
about a month ago or month and a half ago here
in Las Vegas uh then that would be plenty for the
Canadians uh but yeah just not not the greatest of
runs for him right now on the defensive side for
the Habs they're allowing just under 3.5 goals per
game it's bottom eight in the league Sam monteal
is going to be in net tonight for 3 and one with
a 908 safe percentage but with the Way Columbus
is playing right now they've won three of their
last four games including a 5 to2 win against the
Boston Bruins but still I know their underlying
metrics aren't necessarily great offensively
they're scoring less than three goals per game
2.91 but Boon Jenner leading the team right
now with 16 points he has found the back of the
net Drew 11 times four goals over the last five
games alone he's really been pushing that offense
forward trying to will them some wins during the
stretch yeah and also now the franchise is alltime
leader in games played so congratulations to him
the longest most games played of any blue jacket
in NHL history a franchise that is now uh shocking
to me as an older I guess middle middle Millennial
uh that is now over 20 years old but Bo Jenner mid
mid- Millennial yeah late 80s I think that's mid
Millennial so uh Boon Jenner though really good
one or more points in five of his last six games
you mentioned it four goals in that stretch also
three assists and 13 shots so he's not getting a
ton of the shots on goal when you see that over
2 and 1 half atus 176 even in this stretch he's
only averaging just over two a fraction over two
shots on goal per game but he is making the most
of it with seven points uh in that stretch so he's
been very good really leading this team he's on
Pace for 39 goals this season uh an 11 to five
split of goals to assist with his points through
his first 23 games of the year so he has been
producing especially for a Blue Jackets team that
like you mentioned isn't getting a ton of offense
this year at least not getting a lot of Pucks in
the net bu Jenner has been outstanding for this
Blue Jackets team and they have been coming on
as of late as well on on a bit of a run for the
Blue Jackets winning three of their last four
as you mentioned beating a team that is right
at the top of the Eastern Conference standings as
well during that run I know and during this time
I feel like the team does need a little bit more
from a guy like Patrick l Five Points through 13
games in the season he's averaging a shot less
per game compared to what he did last season but
on the defensive side as a team they're allowing
3.4 goals per game I feel like this is going to
be a back and forth battle between two teams
that are kind of trying to find their footing
but right now the Blue Jackets definitely have the
upper hand and odds makers obviously see that as
well this is going to be a really fun game to
watch we have the Hales in Columbus taking on
the Columbus Blue Jackets that game on tonight 700
p.m. eastern time on ESPN Plus sportset in Valley
Sports next up let's take you to the Big Apple
the Red Wings are in town to take on the red
hot New York Rangers this is the second time that
the Rangers will be hosting the wings in the last
three weeks the wings have some excitement right
now surrounding them with another I guess you
could say mid Millennial and Patrick MC Patrick
Kane officially signing a year contract coming
back from hip resurfacing surgery I know he's
not necessarily going to get a ton of minutes
on the ice he's an older guy he's still aging
like a fine wine though but what does he add to
this winged wheel team in the Detroit Red Wings I
mean certainly depth and when you're also talking
about a team that like Detroit adding a guy that's
been there that's been to the postseason that's
won Stanley Cups is always going to be helpful in
trying to take that next step with the franchise
I like the addition of Patrick Kane uh this is
going to be an interesting match up here too I
do like that we're talking about this game here
because this is going to basically be some trivia
questions down the line after Kane retires years
from now where it's going to be the I know we he
played in Chicago for so many years what are his
other teams we've got the Rangers we've got the
Red Wings he's just making it to play for all
of the American original six teams if he gets
up to Boston at some point uh but yeah it's a I
think it's a really good addition it's going to
help uh kind of flesh out this Detroit Red Wings
team and really make them a bit deeper in depth
especially when we get towards the second half
of the season going into the postseason always
crucial in the NHL yeah it's definitely going to
be fun to watch him back on the ice back playing
the Red Wings are going to be without their
Captain Dylan Lin due to injury in this one
they have one three straight games since returning
from Sweden and in that stretch they've only given
up three goals and two of those wins are against
the Bruins and the Devils so speak of the devil
the Red Wings are rolling right now offensively
they're top four in the league they're averaging
3.7 goals per game David pan though 11 points on
the year seven goals four assists talk about that
depth scoring he's really provided that from the
third line don't you think yeah I mean what more
could you ask for out of a guy who's in your
middle six there than what David pan has been
able to accomplished seven goals four assists his
last two games three goals no assist six shots on
goal he has been on a bit of a tear as of late
but his previous 12 uh prior to those two so
it's a two game run but the previous 12 only two
goals and two assists so uh he's been really good
basically in this last week and he kind of broke
out of a bit of a slump from that last season 24
goals 32 assists in 82 games so uh he has been
really good in these last couple of games and
when he is on when he is contributing he can do
some big things cuz he's not that far removed from
being a top six and possibly even a Topline player
uh when you go back just a handful of years so uh
we know he's capable of producing as he gets a bit
older here uh being in that middle six is a really
good spot and again especially when you had a guy
like Patrick Kane a guy like David pra being able
to put up some decent numbers in the middle six
is going to be even better if you're a Detroit
Red Wings fan but again the last two games he's
really been producing for that if he can keep that
going and not fall back into that bit of a drought
that he had had for the previous few weeks before
that I think that's going to be a really good but
again time will kind of tell if he's going to be a
bit more consistent for the rest of the season as
opposed to just streaky consistency is definitely
the key word defensively the wings allowing three
goals per game but the Rangers on the other side
they sit at the top of the Metro after winning
three of their last four they're seven2 and one
in their last 10 yes I know they got crushed by
the savers on Monday five to one but crazy stat
about this Rangers team they have not lost two
games in a row all season long which is really
difficult to do I know we're only a third of
the way through the season at this point but
that's still a crazy stat for them offensively
they're middle of the pack they're scoring 3.3
goals per game they have the third best power
play in the league so they're definitely going
to take advantage on the man Advantage but mik a
bandage Ed he's been great this year 15 points in
20 games five goals 10 assists what's impressed
you most about the way he's been playing and the
red hot Rangers right now to start the year yeah I
mean New York relies on a guy like M because Ben A
J to really produce and provide that offense
and he's been doing that like you mentioned
last year an amazing season with 91 points he's
currently on a four game point streak that's seen
him net three goals pick up two assists on top
of that and nine shots in his last four games as
well uh only one shot over his last two games
but he has at least 12 games of three or more
shots this year so if you're seeing that minus
154 basically half the time more than half the
time that is paid out taking the over on zabad
for two and a half shots on goal and going up
against team like Detroit whose shots and goal uh
four and against are basically even right around
the 30 Mark per game this season uh could be very
interesting but zad when you're talking about that
offense just for the New York Rangers with the
ability with artmi panan who has 30 points which
is unreal Chris krider's got 20 so far and zabi
with 15 uh he has been producing and creating a
lot five goals 10 assists so far on the season uh
and he's a guy that I mean you know the Rangers
had some pretty high hopes last year this year
and it it relies on guys like zabad producing
and performing at kind of the level that he's
going right now I mean he's not on Pace for 91
points but he's on Pace to still contribute
and help out this team offensively yeah and
really good news on the defensive side for this
team Adam Fox activated from the IR expected to
suit up after missing the last 10 games with a
lower body injury that's just going to add to
a defense that's already one of the best in the
league third from the top right now they're only
allowing 2.45 goals per game eigor sterk's been
great 916 save percentage I feel like the Rangers
are a team that's really proven themselves this
season that they need business they want to come
out they want to come out on home ICE they want to
play hard it is the first half of a back-to-back
for the wings they play on Thursday in Chicago so
this is definitely going to be an in interesting
matchup but we do our same game parlays I know our
friend Tom Veo has a good one for this game Tom
take it away thanks Lauren my favorite same game
parlay for the Rangers and the Red Wings starts
off with the Rangers money line they're coming
off a loss and they're one of the best teams in
League they've shown they can bounce back well
after losses they're also expecting to get Adam
Fox back into lineup which is a big boost and
the Red Wings are expected to be without Dylan
Lin so removing one of the best players from the
Red Wings and the Rangers adding one back should
only be a positive for the Rangers next up over
six and a half goals both teams are on the top
half of the league when it comes to goals scored
per game the red rings are all the way up at 3
.7 goals per game and both teams are in the top 10
League when comes to power play percentage so they
can get the scoring going when they have the man
advantage and then finally Chris ceded to record
three plus shots on goal he's averaging 2.6 shots
on goal per game this year he's coming off a game
where he had only won and more importantly the
Red Wings they're in the bottom half of the league
when it comes to Total shot attempts allowed per
60 Minutes in 5v5 situations so if I'm expecting
the Rangers to bounce back overall we should see
some of their top players like prder on the first
forward line in the first Power Play stepping up
their offense and really pushing the goals forward
back to you guys thanks so much Tom appreciate
it drew what you think of his SGP I think that
over is going to be the one that kind of can be
hit or miss on it because Detroit hasn't lost by
multiple goals in their last seven they are 4-1
and two with no multi-goal losses in their last
seven games so for that over to hit unless we're
going to break that Trend we're talking about a
4-3 game and that's a that could be a little
bit tricky but I do like it overall I do like
what he's doing overall that uh I I think that
I sweating that over is a little bit that that
might come down to the wire there on that one to
see what happens I always feel like over sweats
though are better than UND sweats because when
you're just hoping a team doesn't score a goal
that's always just a little bit more stressful
but I'm excited for this game this is the game
of the night in my opinion we have the Red Wings
in the Big Apple taking on the New York Rangers
that game on tonight 7:30 p.m. eastern time on
TNT or you can stream it live on Max last but not
least let's head To the Left Coast the West Coast
the Caps have traveled from the nation's capital
to take on the LA Kings and these are two teams
right now that are trending in extremely opposite
directions at this point the Caps yes they've
been hot in mid November they had a five-game
win streak going until they dropped the last two
games including Monday to the Sharks which is the
bottom team in the National Hockey League right
now I know the Caps are wantan to get going to
want to get back on track offensively they've been
a little stagnant they've they're averaging only
2.33 goals per game second to last in the NHL and
only three players on their team Drew have double
figure points and the most is obious or o Obi oby
oie with 12 points but Dylan stro he's been good
at least helping to produce on the offensive side
10 points in 18 games including a team leading
eight goals but they need to find the back of the
net a little bit more than they are right now to
try to have more success this season don't you
think oh absolutely you've got to get that offense
going and Strow on his last three Road games does
not have any points goals or assists so he hasn't
been able to find the back of the net or create
goals just yet for the year though on the road
in his previous three games he had four goals uh
away from home so uh it's a bit interesting he's
still on Pace for 36 goals this season but not
a lot of assists last year of course uh had a 65
point campaign you mentioned a bit of a slump it's
it's interesting when you're looking at Washington
where they are in the standings they still have
a lot of games in hand four games in hand on the
Flyers who are one Point ahead of them and three
games in hand on the Carolina Hurricanes who only
four points ahead of Washington in the standings
so that's a bit interesting they're in a position
where it's not the end of the world here even if
you do go through a bit of a slow stretch even
if you do lose to San Jose that is not the end
of the world because they have so many games in
hand on the teams that are ahead of them in the
standings Dylan stro though going to need to get
that offense going away from home like he did for
the first few Road games of the Season hasn't done
it lately uh but uh it's going to be a tough task
to do that against an LA Kings team here because
they're on home ice and the kings are just one of
the best teams in the NHL right now that's what I
was just going to say because the Caps have the
second worst offense in the NHL they're going
up against the best defense in the NHL right
now but still on the caps on the defensive
side they are top eight they're allowing 2.78
goals per game but again the Kings top offense
in the league at this point so it's like what is
going on right now the LA Kings going up against
the the capitals Darcy keer for the Caps he has
an 894 save percentage on the season through 10
games he's going to have a tough challenge because
let's get into the LA Kings they are hot five-game
winning streak everything's going right at this
point they're eight one and one in their last 10
games and offensively they're averaging a league
best four goals per game nine players in double
figure Point totals and Trevor Moore has been on
a tear 19 points in 19 games including 11 goals I
feel like their offense is Unstoppable at this
point Drew how do the Caps slow them down I I
think you just have to count on your goal tending
to keep the pucks out of the neck because I don't
know that you can really slow down this LA Kings
team at least not the way they've been going as
of late Trevor Moore with a point in four of his
last five games and we're talking about a Kings
the Kings offense being what it is in a division
with Vegas and Edmonton the Kings have been the
standout team at least lately obviously the golden
knights had an incredible start to the season and
know was talking about it just the other day about
how they've kind of hit a bit of a hiccup as Conor
McDavid has come on but Trevor Moore has been
outstanding with four goals and three assists
in his last five games played he's on Pace for 47
goals and 35 assists this season he has been just
outstanding for this LA Kings team and I know I
just keep using that word to describe the Kings
but what more can you say the Kings have been
just uh exceeding all expectations so far with
where they are four games in hand on bgk they've
got a five-game winning streak going they're 29
Points 133 and three just incredible what the
Kings have been able to do and Trevor Moore one
of the many players as you mentioned nine players
in double digit points on the year Adrien kempe
Kevin fola tied for the team lead they've each
got 20 so far this season this king's offense I
just would not bet against them at this point in
the year because who can slow them down right now
yeah I wouldn't bet against their offense or their
defense because right now defensively they're also
sitting at the top of the league in terms of goals
allowed per game only allowing 2.37 goals per game
cam talbat has really come out strong this season
103 and one 931 save percentage 2.02 goals against
average this could be a good spot to take the
Kings Puck Line Drew how do you approach a game
like this where you have one of the best teams in
the NHL going up against a team that's not bad but
they're not great by any means they're kind of
trying to figure it out yeah with the Kings at
minus 215 there's kind of three options that I
always look to it's Puck line it's uh Kings to
win in regulation because obviously if if they're
going to win by multiple goals it has to come in
regulation uh or the team total for Washington
taking them under I think it's set to two and
a half it might be a little bit juic but you're
talking about a team that offensively hasn't done
a ton against a team that defensively has just
controlled the game so uh any of those I think
are really good options and it's kind of just a
question of because the under for this game might
be intriguing if the capitals uh don't get to two
or three goals I think that this the under at six
and a half might be an interesting play as well
just because I don't think Washington's going to
get all that many goals in this game against the
LA Kings and I mean you could even even in a 4-1
situation under six and a half is going to pay out
and that kind of thing so uh there's a number of
ways you can bet on the Kings the money line is
the only one I would not take because minus 215
it just there's gonna be more interesting ways
to bet on the Kings to win the juice ain't worth
to squeeze at that point that is the last game
on our three- game slate tonight the Caps all
the way in LA taking on the Los Angeles Kings
that game is on tonight 10:30 p.m. eastern time
on ESPN Plus in your Regional Sports networks
let's take you back to the top we got the Habs
in Columbus taking on the blue Jack at 700 p.m
Eastern Time on ESPN plus and then we send you
to the Big Apple the Red Wings in town an original
six match up the wings taking on the Rangers 7:30
Eastern Time on TNT and you can stream it live
on HBO Max it's going to be a fun three game
slate tonight and guess what there's 14 games
going on tomorrow so Drew you said we're here
to make money and make friends we're giving the
people what they want we have an extended hourong
show tomorrow that we are so excited about
so make sure to tune in um can you even wait
Drew I I no I can't I'm going to start looking
towards tomorrow's games in probably an hour I
mean this is uh I love those games where we get
almost every team in the NHL is playing tomorrow
that is it's like a Christmas in November it's
almost December anyway so might as well Christmas
on the last day of November we'll see you guys
then until then peace out have a great [Music]
day